it's faster to be hearing in Birmingham
everybody but before I go any further I
just want to check one thing as well is
everybody here are we all here by and
large proud conservatives are we proud
of the oldest and most successful party
in all Western democracies do we intend
to fight the next election under the
conservative banner and now other are
there any defectors or yeah
are there any quitters or splitters
anybody being feeling a bit yellow
around the edges like a kipper because
at this conference we can say with pride
that London remains not just the capital
of England but thanks to the wisdom of a
clear majority of Scots it is the
capital of Britain and the capital of
the United Kingdom and will remain so
and will I believe remain safe for our
lifetimes you have permission to play
which you sow to date and
with
when the when the great flywheel and I
want those homes marketed first and sold
first to people from this country and
people from London and not necessarily
to oligarchs from the planet zorg though
I am very far I can see my housing
advice on my TV
I want you I want to reassure you I'm
very far from the August and most of My
Ancestors turn out to have come from Zog
so I'm I'm generally and by the way I am
generally in favor of foreign investment
but that is the challenge to build more
homes and one way or another we will
need 1 billion 1 billion next 10 years
we will need 1 billion of these bricks
so brick you will not be alone brick
from music this brick will not be alone
when it when it comes to London and that
is a lot of work